el cuerpo humano contiene órganos como
los huesos
el cerebro el corazón y los órganos
reproductores
las células básicas que originan todas
las células diferentes en estos órganos
se denominan células madre
un tipo de célula madre es el óvulo de
una mujer
que el espermatozoide de un hombre
fértil hizo
esta célula única denominada cigoto es
la primera célula de un ser humano en
desarrollo también se la denomina célula
madre totti potente porque puede formar
cualquier tipo de células en el cuerpo
así como también el cordón umbilical y
la placenta después de que un cigoto se
divide varias veces se convierte en un
embrión en fase temprana denominado
blastocito
las células madre embrionarias provienen
de las células que se encuentran dentro
del blastocito
son pluripotentes esto significa que
pueden formar cualquier tipo de células
en el cuerpo
pero no las células del cordón umbilical
ni las de la placenta
en el laboratorio las células madre
embrionarias se donan de embriones
sobrantes creados durante la
fertilización in vitro
la fertilización in vitro es un
procedimiento que ayuda a la mujer a
quedar embarazada
otro tipo de célula madre es una célula
madre adulta pequeños grupos de estas
células se encuentran en algunos órganos
como la piel después del nacimiento o en
la adultez
las células madre adultas son multi
potentes esto significa que sólo se
pueden convertir en algunos tipos de
células diferentes relacionadas con el
órgano en las que se encuentran por
ejemplo la piel contiene una pequeña
cantidad de células madre adultas que
pueden dividirse para crear nuevas
células madre adultas cutáneas
o pueden convertirse en células madre
más especializadas para reemplazar a
aquellas que se pierden debido al
envejecimiento celular oa daños
en el laboratorio los científicos ahora
pueden inducir o provocar que una célula
del cuerpo regular como una célula
cutánea se transforme en una célula
madre pluripotente al igual que las
células madre embrionarias estas células
madre pluripotentes inducidas pueden
convertirse en cualquier tipo de célula
del cuerpo
los científicos estudian las células
madre para aprender cómo y por qué se
convierten en muchos tipos de células
diferentes
en el futuro estas células podrían
utilizarse para regenerar tejidos y
órganos dañados debido a una lesión o
enfermedad
la terapia con células madre es un
procedimiento que utiliza células madre
para tratar una enfermedad o una
afección
actualmente la terapia con células madre
solo trata enfermedades y cánceres de la
sangre
por ejemplo en la leucemia la médula
ósea del paciente genera muchos glóbulos
blancos anormales que no pueden cumplir
su función de combatir infecciones con
el tiempo estas células anormales
desplazan la producción de glóbulos
blancos sanos
en la terapia de células madre para la
leucemia denominada trasplante de
células madre hematopoyéticas un médico
toma una muestra de sangre o de médula
ósea del paciente o de un donante
en algunos casos la sangre de un donante
puede provenir del cordón umbilical de
un bebé después de su nacimiento estas
muestras de tejido contienen células
madre hematopoyéticas o encargadas de
formar la sangre sanas
y luego los médicos les dan a los
pacientes medicamentos para
quimioterapia o utilizan radiación para
matar los glóbulos blancos anormales y
sus células madre
una vez que las células madre ya no
están el médico trasplante a las células
madre hematopoyéticas sanas de las
muestras de tejido al paciente
estas células madres sanas generarán más
células sanguíneas incluyendo glóbulos
blancos normales que le permitirán al
organismo combatir las infecciones